[Music]
dino here i'm with apogee which is part
of google cloud
this video is apogee 101 we'll learn how
to create a proxy and begin serving
traffic
let's dive in after you've created your
trial account
sign in to apigee.com
click the api proxies icon and you'll
see the proxies list
now in your organization you may see one
or more api proxies
what we want to do is create a new one
we'll do that with the wizard from
within the wizard first
select reversed proxy we'll name the
proxy
specify a base path i'll say more about
that in a moment
and specify the back end target this is
what the proxy will connect to
for this demonstration we'll use a
public api that returns a json payload
then we specify our security
requirements for now we will have
no security specify the virtual hosts on
which this proxy will be active
i prefer the tls enabled vhost
specify the environment test for now
done this proxy is now active ready to
handle traffic
let's click through to the proxy editor
to see the overview of the proxy we
just created
we can see all the details we provided
also we can see the url
where we can invoke this api proxy
let's try it just click this url and it
opens in another
browser tab and we can see the json
returned by the proxy
so the proxy is working
let's flip back to the apigee
administrative ui
clicking the develop tab gives us the
chance to modify the proxy produced by
the wizard
i can change the deployment status of
the proxy undeploy it
at which point it won't be listening
anymore
i can change any of the choices i made
previously
and i can configure additional policies
that will run for each inbound request
before the request is proxy to the
target or
policies that run on the response after
the response is received from the target
but before it is sent to the original
client
apigee proxies are smart and
configurable
let's add a rate limiting policy to this
proxy a quota enforcement
to do that i'll click the pre-flow in
the proxy endpoint
and click the plus step icon
here i see a list of the various
policies apogee edge has available
i want the quota policy
let's configure it with a fixed rate
limit of three requests
for every minute to do that i'll just
paste in some simple configuration
then i'll save it and redeploy it
and then flipping back to the other
browser tab i can invoke it again
now there's no change in the behavior of
this api proxy it's still returning json
but after i invoke that proxy more than
three times i get an error that says the
rate limit has been exceeded
the apogee proxy is rejecting the
request because it's exceeding the limit
rate limiting is easy flipping back to
the apogee administrative ui
in the develop tab let me raise that
limit to
oh a thousand requests per minute i can
do it just like that
but surely there are other options for
the quota policy how do i learn about
them
by selecting the policy in the api proxy
editor
i can get a hyperlink that takes me to
the documentation for that policy
here i can learn everything i need to
know about how to use the
quota policy super helpful
if you have questions that are not
answered by the documentation you can
visit the community
find the link to the community in the
apigee administrative ui
search there or ask a new question
friendly apigee experts like me are
always there willing to help you out
in this video you learn the basics of
apogee edge how to create an api proxy
and how to add a policy to a proxy
how to find documentation on a policy
and how to navigate to the apigee
community
in the next video we'll cover how to add
api key verification
to an existing proxy till then i wish
you
strong api mojo